hallo mein name ist luca und es sind 34
grad draußen ich sterbe von daher
entschuldigt bitte das nicht vielleicht
ein bisschen verschwitzt bin und ein
bisschen komisch mehr agieren aber das
bin ich ja sonst auch im raum gotthard
wir befinden uns heute auf einer website
die uns sagte welchen namen sie
eigentlich haben also falls ihr mal
euren namen vergessen habt dann geht
einfach auf diese webseite hier nein
meine damen und herren das verrät einem
dieser website natürlich nicht sondern
diese website sagt einem wie man
beispielsweise als kommandant heißen
würde oder als datei oder als kurian
oder sogar als medien und das finden wir
heute raus ich würde sagen wir fangen
direkt mal mit minion an und zwar witsch
generation do you belong to you
generation alpha bin ich auf jeden fall
ne
ich weiß nicht mehr wann ich geboren bin
ich bin 1996 geboren also natürlich
millennial dann what do you in my life
work in office network in office oder
vielleicht sogar gut questions to train
to figure da und jetzt werden wir nach
unserem tiefsten verlangen gefragt sag
ich meine worte sehr tief ist die sah ja
im innern auto peace compassion date
world personal trotz finding schule oder
understanding the people anders denn in
der bibel
ich bin nämlich dumm und verstehe gar
keinen das ist meine größte stärke heime
bilder verbreitet intelligence keines
kreativität stranger konferenz ich würde
sagen intelligenz auf keinen fall ich
würde sagen kann es also mir sagen
einige leute ich bin ganz nett aber
eigentlich bin ich auch ein totaler spaß
ich habe keine stärken what role you
play off friendships also welche rolle
spiele ich in freundschaften ultimate
macht frentzen love also ich mag es sie
zum lachen zu bringen
ich gebe ihnen immer hilfe wenn sie
welche brauchen ich bin ein
friedensstifter also ein salat
streitschlichter ich war tatsächlich in
der schule immer streitschlichter da
habe ich mich immer voll cool gefühlt
als ich so ein gelbes leibchen um hatte
und so eine gelbe
ich glaub ich sage hart und cool aus ich
würde sagen ich bin meine freunde zum
lachen
deswegen machen wir mal direkt nächste
frage how often do you work auto mein
wird heute drei wochen nicht bei
instagram bei der post ich mal wenn ich
im team bin also falls mir da noch nicht
vor dienstag laden the people and the
gym know me by now also die kennen mich
bei meinem namen aber das impliziert
natürlich nicht wie oft nicht dort warum
habe ich diesen test gemacht hat mich
würde sagen aber sport jetzt denkmal
next what do you dream about the new
sleeper auftrieb da im training oft
alltag will ich ein tier wäre wäre ich
glaube ich einen delfin weil ich wasser
über alles mag bucket list nein ich habe
keine bucket list tatsächlich pick one
of the below armenien
also ich muss nochmal
namen eingeben ich heiße logan natürlich
armenien 1 mi und die website sagte
hiromi
stewart
wie lato
ich habe jetzt einfach stewart
allerdings ist das natürlich nicht das
einzige küsst dass ich heute vorbereitet
habe sondern wir machen auch noch das
emo quiz audi am ein foto von mir ich
bin wieder 1996 geboren
hier sind die gleichen fragen sehe ich
gerade ich sag diesmal aber you not
working office dann sage ich wollte sehr
tief ist die sah ja würde ich sagen
personal groß dann machen wir jetzt mal
dass ich intelligent
das kann ich eigentlich nicht ankreuzen
creativity nehme ich dann einfach mal
what we do you play off rangers da sage
ich auch einfach mal ich bringe meine
freude zum lachen dann sag ich mal
fitness ist live ich hab den test
gemacht weil meine frames anchorage
mieter denn ich habe ihn in einem
englischen satz zwei wörter komplett
falsch ausgesprochen gut mein fehler ich
sage ich träume von einer beziehung und
von leuten und ich würde sagen ich wäre
ein hund oder ein wolf ich habe eine
bucket list ja sage ich auch mal
portable audio am mail und als name
schreibe ich jetzt einfach mal luke er
da rein das heißt wir schauen jetzt mal
was meine emo name wäre ein paar
sekunden später
soldier of sorrow
haben
ich war ja diese website
wie ihr vielleicht wisst habe ich da
vorne bei mir im wohnzimmer ein dj
mischpult rumstehen und mixa auch für
mein leben gern als einem jahr lade ich
auf sounds mixtapes hochwald übrigens
auch auf youtube also bald seht ihr mich
auf youtube an turntables rumstehen und
10 20 minuten mitmachen also ja
vielleicht freut ihr euch auch gar nicht
darauf für mich ist es auf jeden fall
ein großer schritt nach vorne weil musik
ein großes thema in meinem leben ist und
ich das jetzt endlich dann auch auf
youtube machen kann weil wir die ganze
rechte sache seit einem halben jahr ja
jetzt gerade klären
das ganze geht das allerdings in die
finale phase in einigen wochen hatte man
erstens dj mix tape hier auf youtube
aber um auf dieses druck zu kommen warum
ich das gerade gesagt habe was wäre
eigentlich mein dj name eigentlich finde
ich laser luca ganz gut was weiß ich
auch auf install as instagram zumal aber
wir beantworten hier jetzt einfach mal
wieder die fragen genauso wie ich sie
auch wirklich beantworten würden wird es
ich kann kein multitasking also dass ich
krieg das nicht hin ich bin schon froh
dass ich denken kann gleichzeitig unsere
high
sag mal meine größte stärke ist man
diese krise explosiv shakes and cars
like to make friends are for sage ich
auch work aussage ich mache ich gar
nicht das fest habe ich gemacht wegen
allen gründen die hier angezeigt werden
ich träume sehr oft von tieren und wenn
ich noch mal ein tier sein würde was
heißt noch mal war ich jeden tier bist
du dumm luca ich wäre eine eule als
nächstes sagen wir einfach ja das ist
relativ verharrt was ich kann keine
tussi tasking gegenteil verkehrt aber
wir sagen jetzt einfach mal ich bin
wieder einmal mein name diesmal richtig
luca das heißt mein die teilnahme meine
damen und herren ich mache demnächst
mixtapes hier auf youtube vielleicht
auch mal irgendwann einen eigenen song
ich werde nie singen nur damit das
glauben an gott
oh mein gott
ich
dj diese bis dahin ist noch in ordnung
hat hacker schon mal ist der dj ist ein
sehr sehr großes hobby von mir und es
ist für mich auch ein sehr sehr großer
traum damit irgendwann eventuell mal in
clubs aufzulegen oder irgendwas hier
gerade in köln das bootshaus ist ein
mega geiler klub ich kenne die leute die
meinten auch schon voll aufs meer wenn
du bock hast dann legt einfach mal auf
durch denke mir dann die ganze zeit so
wenn ich es dann verkaufe und ich bin
kein guter dj und das ganze geht den
bach runter da brauche ich ja noch eine
andere option was ich meinem leben
beruflich mache und da dachte ich an
strippen was mein stripper name ich bin
rentner ist also ich bin netter mensch
würde ich sagen mal in freundschaften
bin ich der der dinge fixed also als
tripper dann eventuell auch manchmal
nicht fix sondern fix
habt ihr den job verstanden werden die
abonnenten
hitze ich bin
ich habe den test gemacht weil es nach
spaß ausgesehen hat ich träume oft dass
ich vor einem krieg weglaufen wenn ich
noch mal wieder gewonnen werden würde
wäre ich eine gazelle einfährt oder eine
giraffe und habe ich eine bucket list
yesim half way through it already nicht
erlebt so viel in meinem leben ich bin
immer noch mail m und mein name ist luca
sage ich einfach mal nen austritt würde
ich jetzt mal anklicken das heißt mainz
dem verstehe ich nicht an da dann das
richtig toller name aber jetzt mal egal
ob das mit produzieren und dj klappt und
auch egal ob ich vielleicht ein gutes
tue werde oder nicht das was ein mensch
auf jeden fall die gern ich rede ganze
ein bisschen komisch weil ich hier noch
so ein ding zwischen den zähnen haben
reiskorn was der mensch immer tun muss
im leben ist essen das heißt wir finden
jetzt mal raus was mein name als essen
wäre also als food wenn da nicht pizza
rauskommt dann bin ich sehr sauer
das funktioniert nicht also wenn ich mir
die kommentare gucke steht hier auch
loslassen work work no no no wir wissen
alle dass davids herausgekommen wäre da
das mit dem food quiz nicht so wirklich
geklappt hat würde ich sagen
schauen wir uns jetzt mal an rich
motivation post
bei der ersten frage müssen einfach eine
farbe auswählen da will ich auf jeden
fall orange auswählen bei der nächsten
frage im hause skifest date of
playstation also wie schaffen wir es
selber quasi ein bisschen runter zu
kommen lanes role playing game
da würde ich nur übels ausrasten ich
würde sagen für access teils er mich
macht das wirklich häufig wenn ich
gestresst dass ich einfach nur lange
runde joggen gehe hier gern word up
about things to put people
hier müssen wir uns ein lebensziel
aussuchen titel best pairs nobody has
gone before auf keinen fall
ich mag das ja gar nicht diese leute die
meinen sie müssten die ganze welt
entdecken also ja klar natürlich so ist
es cool zu reise und neue orte zu
entdecken und viele sagen auch man lebt
dafür um die welt irgendwie zu erkunden
aber ich bin überhaupt nicht so ein
mensch der so denkt verlust sich
eigentlich in diesem video hier erfahrt
ihr noch mega viel über mich
bei mir ist es eher so also ich bin auch
gerne unterwegs aber ich freue mich auch
immer sehr toll wenn ich dann zu hause
bin es gibt zum englischen blogger der
hand von louis und der ist quasi jeden
tag irgendwo anders auf der welt und das
ist schön und und cool und wenn es ihm
spaß macht dann habe ich dort nichts
gegen aber ich find und ich war ja jetzt
auch schon irgendwie viermal in amerika
und europa eigentlich auch schon allen
großen städten so ich bin auch sehr sehr
gern einfach mal eine zeit lang zu hause
mit freunden und familie deswegen würde
ich sagen mein lebensziel ist und die
prada welt also einfach nur verrückt
sein irgendwas machen er wolle sehr
verwirrt time of fashion relaxing on the
beach doing nassen ich kann echt
ganzen tag einfach am strand herumliegen
wann ziehe ich mich verrückt an
ich würde sagen auch nicht vor dem
paradies meiner helfen weil sonst
verkleidete mich richtig komisch
irgendwie herr p gt wie serious engine
most active game of thrones arrow big
bang theory supernatural danach otto war
ich guck keine von diesen serien ich
würde sagen dann doch allerdings am
nächsten big bang theory m ich bin ja
gerade voll im soll diesen trip weil da
ja die zweite staffel rausgekommen ist
der segmente war habe ich durchaus das
geld das fand ich mega
dieses küste hat mir ich sei sheldon
cooper
traurige ist dass mir das wirklich noch
mal freunde gesagt haben an der stelle
wird das heutige video ist allerdings
auch beenden meine damen und herren wenn
es euch gefallen hatte und ihr in dem
video gefallen gefunden gehabt du hast
worte die ich bereits zu beginn dieses
videos gesagt habe meine damen und
herren wenn ihr dieses video gerade
schaut ist der 29 15 in drei tagen also
freitag am ersten sechs kommt um 15 uhr
eine neue kollektion online shop zu shop
adresse kennt ihr glaube ich also
freunde viele davon etwas kaufen möchte
dann tragt es euch schon mal fest in den
kalender ein es gibt eine jeansjacke
reflektiere die zu ein bisschen teurer
sind
aber die sind qualitativ echt krank und
die sind auf jeden fall auch limitierten
auf nur ganz wenige also falls also ja
ich glaube er ist bescheiden
luca jetzt mach doch mal halt die klappe
jetzt hier